Bis plötzlich:
(Stimme aus Fernseher:)
Eine Zahnpasta,
die komplett auf Fluorid
verzichten kann.
Prüfen Sie,
ob Ihre Zahnpasta Fluorid enthält.
* Schreit *
* Titelmelodie *
Okay, Freunde der Sonne,
ich habe mich beruhigt,
habe mir einen Tee gemacht.
Damit wir in aller Ruhe über Fluoride
und Zahnpasta sprechen können.
Es gibt verschiedene fluoridfreie
Zahnpasten auf dem Markt,
das ist erst mal nichts Neues.
Aber als ich beim Fernsehschauen
über diese Werbung stolperte:
- Komplett auf Fluorid verzichten.
...wurde ich ein bisschen getriggert.
(Sprecher:) Die EU hat für die
umstrittene Chemikalie... - Sorry,
bevor wir starten, nur, damit es
keine Missverständnisse gibt:
Fluor und Fluorid
sind nicht dasselbe.
Fluor ist sehr giftig, weil sehr
reaktiv, Fluorid ist recht unreaktiv.
Okay, machen wir weiter.
(Sprecher:) Die EU hat für
die umstrittene Chemikalie Fluorid
in Zahnpasten
strenge Grenzwerte definiert.
Deutsche Wissenschaftler
haben jetzt *piep* entwickelt:
eine Zahnpasta, die komplett
auf Fluorid verzichten kann.
Okay, nur FYI: Die Grenzwerte
für Fluoride in Zahnpasten
wurden bereits 1978 festgelegt und
haben sich seither nicht geändert.
Das ist keine Reaktion auf
irgendwelche neuen EU-Richtwerte.
Es sei denn natürlich, die Reaktion
kommt 40 Jahre zu spät.
(Sprecher:) Prüfen Sie,
ob Ihre Zahnpasta Fluorid enthält.
Wenn ihr schon dabei seid,
prüft doch bitte, ob eure Zahnpasta
schon älter als 40 Jahre alt ist.
Nur, damit das klar ist: Jede
Zahnpasta, die ihr in der EU kauft,
überschreitet
keine Fluorid-Grenzwerte.
(Sprecher:) Ab jetzt auf Fluorid
verzichten, mit *piep* gegen Karies.
Ohne Fluoride gegen Karies.
(Sprecher:) Gegen Karies.
- Okay...
Schauen wir uns doch erst mal an,
wie Karies genau entsteht.
Woraus besteht eigentlich
so ein Zahn?
Der Großteil des Zahnschmelzes
besteht aus einem Mineral namens:
Es ist eine unreine Form
des Hydroxylapatits.
Das heißt nicht,
dass die Zähne schmutzig sind,
sondern chemisch gesehen unrein:
Es ist kein reines Hydroxylapatit.
Um das zu verstehen, ganz kurz:
Was ist eigentlich so ein Mineral?
Ein Mineral ist ein Salz
oder eine Ionenverbindung.
Genauso wie Natriumchlorid,
unser Kochsalz,
oder Calciumcarbonat,
unser Kalk in der Küche.
Auch Hydroxylapatit
besteht aus verschiedenen Ionen,
nämlich aus Kalzium-,
Phosphat- und Hydroxitionen,
die gemeinsam
ein Kristallgitter bilden.
In unseren Zähnen sind aber auch
manchmal andere Ionen zu Gast,
im Kristallgitter.
Z.B. Carbonat- der Fluorid-Ionen.
D.h. selbst in einem festen Material
wie unseren Zähnen,
selbst
in einem festen Kristallgitter,
können sich
einzelne Ionen austauschen.
Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn:
Unsere Zähne sind ein Mineral,
das aus Ionen besteht.
So, wie entsteht jetzt Karies?
Unsere Zähne sind von einem Biofilm
umgeben, genannt Plaque.
In der Plaque hausen
viele kleine Mikroorganismen.
Diese Mikroorganismen freuen sich,
wenn wir Kohlenhydrate
und v.a. Zucker essen, weil
sie das dann in Säure umwandeln.
Säure heißt:
Der pH-Wert in unserem Mund sinkt.
Was bedeutet jetzt ein sinkender
pH-Wert für unser Zahnmineral?
Das ist ganz ähnlich
wie bei dem Kalk in unserer Küche:
Kalk, also Calciumcarbonat,
ist ja deswegen so nervig,
weil es so schlecht
in Wasser löslich ist.
Es sei denn, wir haben
einen tiefen, also sauren pH!
Wenn wir den Kalk mit Essig
oder irgendeinem anderen sauren
Kalkentferner auf die Pelle rücken,
dann löst er sich auf.
Genau das passiert auch
mit unseren Zähnen.
Was dann auch zu den Löchern
führt. Voilà: Karies!
Karies heißt, unsere Zähne
lösen sich auf, man sagt dazu auch:
Wie kann man Karies
jetzt also bekämpfen?
Mit Remineralisation!
Okay, wie geht das?
Kommen wir noch mal zurück
zu unserem unreinen Hydroxylapatit.
Oft ist es so: Je reiner
ein Kristallgitter ist,
desto stabiler
ist die Kristallstruktur
und desto schwerer ist es aufzulösen.
Das Auflösen
wollen wir ja verhindern.
Die fremden Ionen, die sich
im Kristallgitter austauschen,
stören das Kristallgitter
normalerweise.
Mit einer Ausnahme:
und zwar Fluorid.
Das Fluorid-Ion
ist nämlich sehr klein.
Wenn es sich anstelle
eines Hydroxyt-Ions
in das Kristallgitter reinsetzt,
entsteht dadurch ein dichteres
und stabileres Kristallgitter.
In Anwesenheit
von bereits wenigen Fluor-Ionen
kann sich Fluor-Apatit
oder Fluor-Hydroxylapatit bilden,
was viel stabiler ist
als Hydroxylapatit.
Das bleibt beständig bei sauren pH,
das löst sich auf.
Kein Loch - Loch.
Solange also Fluorid-Ionen
im Speichel oder in der Plaque
vorhanden sind, können sie sich
in die Apatid-Struktur hineinbauen
und so die Auflösung verlangsamen
oder sogar verhindern.
Remineralisation nennt man das,
der Zahn kann sich wieder aufbauen.
Na schön, aber es gibt doch bestimmt
eine Alternative zu Fluoriden!
Nehmen wir doch mal als Beispiel
das Produkt aus der Werbung.
Hier wird statt Fluoriden
Hydroxylapatit eingesetzt,
also das Zahnmaterial.
Zähneputzen mit Zahnschmelz quasi.
Klingt erst mal einleuchtend.
Wenn Karies durch die Auflösung
von Zahn entsteht,
fügen wir einfach mehr Zahn hinzu, um
so die Demineralisation aufzuhalten.
Nur, wenn wir uns
diese Grafik anschauen,
erscheint das Ganze
weniger sinnvoll.
Bei tiefem pH,
also ab einem pH von 5,
löst sich Hydroxylapatit schnell auf.
Was bringt es also, über die
Zahnpasta noch mehr Hydroxylapatit
hinzuzufügen,
wenn es sich doch sowieso auflöst?
Wenn wir unsere Zähne
aber mit Fluorid putzen,
entsteht Fluorapatit,
was deutlich weniger löslich ist.
Kein Loch - Loch.
Aber das ist ja
auch nur meine Theorie
nach rein logisch-chemischem
Verständnis.
Vielleicht zeigt
die Praxis ja was ganz anderes.
Schauen wir doch mal
auf der Homepage des Herstellers.
Was sagen die Medien...?
Wen interessiert,
was Wissenschaftler und Ärzte sagen?
Ich möchte wissen,
was "Galileo" dazu sagt.
Da wird ein Experte gegenübergestellt
irgend so einem Random
Schauspieler-Dude in der Bar.
Und am Ende weiß man halt nicht, wem
man jetzt von beiden glauben soll.
Einem Professor vom Bundesinstitut
für Risikobewertung
oder irgendeinem Dude in der Bar?
Schwierig, schwierig...
Schauen wir doch mal lieber,
was die "moderne" Wissenschaft sagt.
Die Wissenschaft sagt,
Fluoride helfen gegen Karies.
Das ist gut untersucht.
Und es ist nicht umstritten.
Das sage nicht ich,
das hab ich aus einer Quelle,
die der Hersteller
selbst auf seiner Seite verlinkt hat.
Awkward...
Aber schauen wir doch mal,
was sonst noch so verlinkt ist.
Hier wird auf eine Studie verwiesen,
wo Kindern 30 Tage lang
einmal Zahnpasta mit und einmal
ohne Hydroxylapatit gegeben wurde.
Diese Zahnpasten
waren aber nicht Fluorid-frei,
deswegen sagt diese Studie
überhaupt nichts darüber aus,
ob Hydroxylapatit
Fluorid ersetzen könnte oder nicht.
Ist ja aber auch blöd,
wenn jemand wirklich in die Studien
reinschaut, die man verlinkt.
Damit kann wirklich keiner rechnen.
Übrigens: Ich möchte nicht leugnen,
dass Hydroxylapatit
nicht untersucht wurde oder wird
und dass es womöglich
positive Wirkungen haben kann
in der Zahnpflege allgemein.
Nur gegen Karies schützt es nicht.
(Sprecher:) Gegen Karies.
- Ausgerechnet der Punkt,
der ist nicht nachgewiesen.
Und noch was räume ich gerne ein:
Es gibt natürlich andere
Karies-Prophylaxen außer Fluoride.
Aber wenn Fluoride
doch so super wirken,
warum sollte man darauf verzichten?
Weil sie giftig sind!
Kann man prinzipiell
zu viel Fluoride haben?
Ja! So wie bei fast allen Stoffen
gibt es Grenzwerte,
die nicht
überschritten werden sollten.
Wenn ihr Studien findet, die sich mit
Toxizität und Fluoriden beschäftigen,
dann schaut bitte auf 2 Sachen.
Nämlich 1. die Konzentration,
und 2. die Art und Weise der Exposer.
Also lokal beim Zähneputzen
oder durch Essen und Trinken.
Die wahrscheinlich toxische Dosis
für einen Menschen
liegt bei 5 mg Fluorid
pro kg Körpergewicht.
Übrigens "propable",
um halt sicherzugehen.
Die "certainly" toxis dose
liegt höher.
Es wird gefährlich,
wenn Kleinkinder, die wenig wiegen,
größere Mengen an Zahnpasta essen.
Deswegen empfehlen Zahnärzte
Kinder-Zahnpasta.
Die ist Fluorid-ärmer, weil
man eben nicht immer verhindern kann,
dass das Kind die Zahnpasta schluckt.
Wenn man zu viel Fluorid
zu sich nimmt,
z.B. durchs Trinkwasser
oder durch die Nahrung,
diese Gefahr besteht hier
in Deutschland nicht,
kann man eine Fluorose erleiden.
Eine Fluorose
kann man aber nicht erleiden,
wenn man sich
ganz normal die Zähne putzt,
ohne die Zahnpasta zu essen.
Weil der Fluorid-Gehalt in Zahnpasten
auf ein wirksames aber
unbedenkliches Limit begrenzt wurde.
Und es ist eure Entscheidung,
es sind auch eure Zähne,
ihr könnt euch die Zähne putzen,
wie ihr möchtet.
Ich will nur, dass ihr Bescheid wisst
und das tut ihr jetzt,
wo ihr das Video
bis hierhin gesehen habt.
Und damit ist meine Arbeit
hier erledigt.
Bleibt sicher!
Untertitel:
ARD Text im Auftrag von Funk (2018)
* Musik *
# Everybody: Plaque!